the Joe Rogan experience and also the
impact that we're having I know this is
not sustainable for people to not work
and stay home for months it's not
sustainable I'm well aware but it's also
amazing for the earth off you you look
at this the pictures they've taken about
the sky above la I mean I went on a hike
early on I could see all the way to like
Pasadena it smells different it does it
doesn't smell it but in in gasoline
doesn't smell it doesn't smell like
you're being poisoned out by a little
[ __ ] a little bit and you are it's not
the same as smoking it's not the same as
smoking but it's right right next door
and that environmental stress that
constant exposure to environment
environmental stress I mean that affects
your mood that affects your health we've
got to all move out into the rural area
doing that where are we going to go we
got to go on another planet with Biden
and l ron Hubbard people in South Dakota
right now go and stay out of here
Arizona is gonna be the new la I mean
we're all gonna have to move there
Arizona you can have a gun it's easy to
get a gun cheap house yeah cheap house
cactus that shoot needles at ya
literally living inside of Satan's dick
for three months out of the year though
yeah three months of the year it's a
hundred and forty five thousand degrees
it's a brutal existence people aren't
meant to live in the desert everything's
dry crispy and trying to kill you you're
the noise at night what was that
creature
Odie's rattlesnakes and occasion they
have Jaguars you know that's one of the
rare places in North America outside of
Mexico that we occasionally see Jaguar
yeah they have Jaguars that have been
spotted on trail cams and the biologists
these wildlife biologists watch it very
carefully because there's never been a
really strong at least there's no real
history of a really strong supply of
Jaguars in this country it's primarily a
Central and South American animal as
well as a Mexican animal is it something
that got loose from Joe exotics no it's
a real real [ __ ] Jaguar that made its
way from Mexico I mean its habitat is
like just deteriorating and it's
cruising around Arizona that's wild
it's a [ __ ] it picked a [ __ ] spot like
the
[ __ ] imagine being a Jaguar any
dealing with the drug trade like you
think you're the number-one problem and
then the these cartels that are sneaking
coke and just [ __ ] shooting at you
like [ __ ] I thought I was running things
out here and then you got a cousin who's
like a cousin Jaguar lives up in Oregon
he's like bro you got to come up here
there's so many trees it's nice you can
breathe look at this [ __ ] one
wandering around I have that tattooed on
me so see the skin down there in the
middle side where they're looking at
that's the yeah they found out that this
one Jaguar that they had been spotting
on trail cameras have been killed in
Mexico and what turned into a [ __ ]
rug they turn them into a rug yeah how
do you feel about that somebody who
hunts all these like that's what women
see right before men go down on them
that's what it looks like beautiful you
should bring that [ __ ] I need that
picture that colors my office right
Jaime we need it on metal that's
beautiful get that please take a
screenshot right now find that that
needs to be in the studio don't lose it
that is probably a Republican website
look Jaguars returning to Southern
Arizona you see exciting yeah sighs that
[ __ ] encampment yeah that's in a zoo
that's but just still look at the size
that [ __ ] okay lady
they're like 200 pounds those [ __ ]
cats they're big yeah they're big
they're solo hunters right well when you
trip balls apparently in the in the
Amazon when the guys do ayahuasca and
the Amazon they see Jaguars like a
Jaguar entity comes to you yeah you see
like Jaguar spirits you need to get away
out of your own show I just think I
don't know why I was I don't know when
he did that one but I think it was a
really interesting theory about why that
is and that the theory is that the more
people take a psychedelic drug the more
their experience and who they are
becomes a part of the psychedelic
experience for the next person whoa back
to that consciousness right so when
these people were tripping on ayahuasca
in a place where they've been tripping
on ayahuasca for 10,000 years
they see things that these people who've
trip before them were terrified of like
snakes okay Jaguars and in [ __ ]
dragons that come from the sky have you
done ayahuasca only done DMT which is
the the chemical version
of ayahuasca I haven't done so it's like
a synthetic you don't throw up and you
don't [ __ ] your pants and it only lasts
20 minutes it's not fun
I want to shart and not have to explain
myself I'm very interested in doing it I
just had I would have to carve away the
time to get ready for it and also make
sure I'm doing it with someone who's a
reputable person and then the problem is
that it's it's not legal so it should be
legal I have a friend who's really
working on what I mean it's not legal so
you don't you never know what you're
getting you have to get through word of
mouth
you know you have to trust people
sketchy it's always sketchy when
whenever you're dealing with anything
whether it's mushrooms or any LSD if
anything yeah well if someone's offering
you some incredibly potent thing and you
don't have a chain of command you don't
you have a lab this came from you don't
know and like when you get into the
world of psychedelic drugs
it becomes very [ __ ] weird you have
to tread lightly because you don't read
very very slowly there's no there's no
FDA he's no there's no ID a for it and
so you're right you're dependent upon
these people who are doing these
journeys and trips in their homes my
friend Jackie staying has a really cool
psychedelic platform it's I think it's
called meet Delic and and she promotes
healthy ways to have a journey in her
the one thing she says cuz I've talked
to her about it I'm like I want to do it
but I'm scared she always says safety
first like it's so good to meet a sitter
and the environment means like you said
the environment needs to be right I've
never done it but I would only go off of
someone like that who is like you know
knows the step
[Applause]